wer alle das ist klar wir brauchen den
booster und das schnell das hat auch die
kanzlerin klar gemacht aber es ist nicht
genug lieblings impfstoff dabei und tag
es ist kaum zu glauben darüber wollen
wir sprechen mit peter tiede unserem
chefreporter bei und texter hat an allen
ecken und enden schönen guten morgen
peter wie kann das sein wird das ist die
große preisfrage das ist die preisfalle
die entspannen wir beantworten muss also
wir haben erst die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
kanzlerin da wird beschlossen boostern
für alle also nicht nur für die über
70-jährigen oder über 60-jährigen oder
die immunschwachen sondern für alle und
am nächsten tag verkündet dann der
gesundheitsminister dass ausgerechnet
bayern trägt der impfstoff mit dem sich
96 prozent der deutschen bisher haben
muss sondern ist also diejenigen die
sich am fuß fassen zu 96 prozent mit
bayern und diesen impfstoff der wird
jetzt verknappt und das versteht
wirklich niemand mehr es ist insgesamt
ist er genügend impfstoff da man hat
noch moderner auf lager aber ich habe
heute morgen auch den verzweifelten
sprecher von ihren sparen der nicht
verstehen will warum die
berichterstattung nicht so läuft wie das
herr standen ja gerne hätte auch erklärt
die haben den kühlschrank voll mit pepsi
und mit cook und die leute sagen aber
wir wollen coke und pepsi bleibt drin
und da kannst du machen was du willst du
christ die leute nicht gezwungen wenn du
wenn du noch da ist und ganz
offensichtlich möchte man das so
verknappen dass die leute dann auch
sagen okay dann gibt mir das moderne
impfstoffe und iren sparen hat ein
zweites problem man hat der kovacs
initiative von der un also die gibt
impfstoff in arme staaten versprochen
dass wir noch in diesem jahr 100 100
millionen dosen impfstoff spenden und da
hinken wir auch hinterher und die
biotech lieferung für november knapp
neun millionen dosen die geht wohin die
geht an kovacs sie geht ins ausland und
damit bleibt wir uns nicht genug übrig
jetzt hat man den eindruck die einen
sparen gegen den rest der welt alle
sagen mensch du hast da ein fehler
gemacht über minister bitte korrigiert
das doch oder bitte gesteht es zumindest
ein dass da wieder was gewaltig schief
gelaufen ist und der minister steht da
und sagt mir ist so alles paletti doch
richtig gemacht löst er das heute noch
auf er wird in rund einer stunde eine
pressekonferenz geben glaubst du dass er
dann doch sagen wird müsst ich habe mir
das noch mal überlegt da ist etwas
schief gelaufen also das ist richtig
bock muss gebaut hat und das sind eine
welle entgegen stieg und zwar von
überall also es gibt niemanden der ihnen
dafür lob also das ist ihm aufgefallen
dass ist auch entspannt nicht entgangen
und entspannen hat am wochenende bei
bayern kann fragen lassen ob man nicht
doch irgendwie noch irgendwo ein paar
impfdosen hat und siehe da bei und tag
des bundes für andere kunden um guckt
noch mal in den lagern nach der im werk
in pools das ist dass es in belgien das
ist das große feuerwerk damit bayerns
hergestellt hauptsächlich und guckt da
noch mal nach und siehe da man ist wohl
noch mal fündig irgendwann nach unseren
informationen ein fehler und zwar noch
regierung aus unseren feldern von bayern
tag müssen die minister zum wiederholten
male retten mit extra lieferung das war
ja schon zum start so auch damals
wodurch als das war vor einem jahr das
war im dezember
2020 2020 altstadt und das sind dagegen
als eher daneben gingen als wir diese
bilder hatten mit den lkw hinten ein
kistchen dritte runde war und das war
dann die große impfstoff lieferung auch
damals hat biontech aus dem jahr aus die
mir 21 lieferung vorgezogen auch lassen
soll jetzt wieder passieren aus dem
januar februar 2022 werden jetzt
lieferung vorgezogen das heißt aber auch
dass andere kunden mit impfstoff unter
umständen später beliefert werden weil
deutschland wieder mehr impfstoff
braucht weil wir wieder von vorn herein
zu wenig bestellt man war schlicht und
ergreifend nicht darauf eingestellt dass
die leute das so früh die empfehlung
kommt muss dann für alle und dass die
leute wirklich also zumindest tischen
schon geimpft sind das die dann die
durch zentrum und die arztpraxen sturm
es fühlt sich an wie eine kleine
zeitschleife die wir da drehen kritik
gibt's ordentlich zum beispiel auch wir
schauen mal rein von manuela schwesig
sind die hat ganz klar gesagt dass sie
mich einverstanden ist mit der arbeit
von ihren sparen gerade da schon einmal
rein sie sagt einen tag nach der
forderung von kanzlerin merkel alle so
schnell wie möglich zu boostern wird das
gesundheitsministerium brocken in das
ins getriebe ich habe kein verständnis
mehr für dieses hin und her von minister
sparen welche brocken sind das ganz
konkret peter von denen manuela schwesig
da spricht hier wird mal rein in so
einer arztpraxis und ich habe das
problem zu hause meine frau arzthelferin
arbeitet einem medizinischen
versorgungszentrum die sind alles
angestellte ärzte die haben sich
entschlossen okay wir machen auch
samstag auf unser ziel so viele leute
bussen wie möglich da geht es nicht um
verdienst oder um irgendetwas so eine
angestellte ärzte die machen das alle
nur gegen freizeitausgleich
extraschichten beim beim booster und
dann und
die impfen auch noch zwei krankenhäusern
mit also das gesamte personal
du kannst nicht zwei extra slots
aufmachen für zwei extra impfstoffe weil
moderner das da ist die verunsicherung
ähnlich groß wie es einmal war bei
astrazeneca damals weil da gab es eine
stiko empfehlung der einschränkung nicht
mit unter 30 jährige nicht mehr für
schwangere da haben die leute ein echo
das kennen sie von astrazeneca bisher
dann vom markt war quasi und die wollen
dann diesen impfstoff nicht wenn die
sagen sich erfindet und unter
30-jährigen nicht schwangere nicht ist
da vielleicht doch was ist nix ist ein
bomben impfstoff der ist super ist ein
ganz toller impfstoff würde ich auch
neben kreuz impfung macht sogar sinn
biotec moderne also wer vorher beim tec
hatte jetzt moderne zunimmt macht
absolut sinn aber die leute sind
verunsichert und die leute rufen an die
haben jeden morgen 200 anrufe auf dem
anrufbeantworter müssen termine machen
und die leute wollen termine machen bei
doktor lipp termine du kannst nichts
weist trotz aufmachen oder aber es kommt
einer der dann sagt okay gibt mir
moderner dann machst du die viola auf
und schmeißt den ganzen rest weg weil du
findest niemanden anders ist logistisch
für größere praxis schlicht und
ergreifend nicht zu leisten klar der
dorfarzt bei denen oma perücke mal um
die ecke kommen der kriegt das
vielleicht warum wir hin und das dinge
ist der minister hat sich selber
boostern lassen mit womit peter mit
23 1 helfen offenbar für ryan tag
entschieden am 8 2 liter sind und der
damals aufgerufen jeder soll sich
bewusst sein der hat wahrscheinlich an
seinen eigenen aufruf nicht geglaubt das
ist ja das tragen